girls we don't run the world but would
things be better if we did women make up
half the world's population but only 22%
of the world governments here in the
u.s. we don't even hit that when it
comes to women in Congress we ranked
73rd in the world lower than Kenya
Namibia and Ecuador so why does it
matter that women lead anyway well
besides the fact that we are the bearers
of life women lawmakers bring something
different and sometimes better to the
table according to a study of the US
House of Representatives in a 20-year
period women sponsored more bills and
attracted more co-sponsors to their
bills than men those bills got more
press attention and survived longer in
the legislative process two women also
raised more money for their home
districts than men get it girls women
are much more Kendu and you know less
about the political theatrics and more
about well how can we solve this problem
I can guarantee you 51% of women in
Congress we wouldn't have wasted the
last four years debating whether women
should have access to contraception
women also focus on different issues
than men specifically ones that
strengthen communities like education
childcare and family health so what
happens when women rule let's look at a
country that ranks number one in women
lawmakers no it's not Finland it's not
Norway it's Rwanda after the 1994
genocide that left around 1 million dead
the remaining population was 70% women
facing a huge power vacuum in government
women stepped up ran for office and got
it done they passed common-sense laws
allowing women to own property and open
their own bank accounts and they focused
on laws protecting children and women
since 2000 the child mortality rate has
plummeted and life expectancy went up by
16 years women are writing the script
that they are saying you are not
accepting the
they also established a quota that at
least 30% of Rwanda Parliament has to be
women over a hundred other countries
have some sort of similar quota
including basically all of South America
Europe and most of Africa
Sweden's party quotas were established
back in the 70s and that country is now
revered as one of the best places to be
a woman with paid maternity leave and
one of the smallest gender pay gaps in
the world but having more women leaders
isn't necessarily a cure-all pill for
sexism and it doesn't mean that those
countries have more say reproductive
rights Argentina Brazil and Chile have
all had female presidents and abortion
is still illegal
Bolivia rates second for women in
government but still female politicians
there are routinely subjected to
harassment and violence even in
progressive Seattle Washington the
majority woman City Council was
inundated with sexist and violent hate
mail after they voted down a mega Sports
Arena it goes beyond politics though
studies show companies that have more
gender equity perform better than those
without it and female bosses create work
environments that are more flexible and
open to employee feedback of course not
every woman is guaranteed to lead in the
same way and more than just quotas a lot
has to be done to position women for
these roles in the first place but it
looks like with more women in charge
everyone wins can you handle that